ah ah
j'ai maintenant du fait qu'il veut quand
même
parce que la fij et 15 piges bonjour
c'est la police si on est en france on
n'est pas des états unis et à en changer
c'est quoi le problème le problème si
les battes de base-ball que vous emmener
sur les interventions
les cowboys n'ont plus leur place au
sein de cette maison
t'imagines le bordel pas mais stable et
la femme de son boss
mika sperme est resté calme pendant dix
ans il vient de braquer une bijouterie
pourquoi tu sais ce qu'ils voulaient
choix parce à 10 soit c'est mes
émissions vous avez pris un sacré coup
devient bon depuis quand on fait des
petits pas car ils ont craché le morceau
de ces foutus pour toi tu peux dire à ta
copine quatre jours du petit cul pour
être crédible en lui son fils par un
cache d'hier c'était seulement les prix
la ramasse ils ont un coup d'avancé à
chaque fois
encore soit rendue et j'espère bien
ça c'est très bien surtout au cours de
stages
maintenant tu arrives allait bien il
vous laisse vous défouler ressent pas je
suis si mon problème je suis trop gentil